at this altitude I can
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as well
WordPress lead developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg now valued at
more than a billion dollars have used
LegalZoom to help with their business
needs specifically in his case to form
his company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NDA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get all a cart style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest i don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code tim t IM at checkout
capital T lowercase I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
well hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is
typically my job to deconstruct
world-class performers across all
different industries and areas of
expertise this episode is going to be
short and sweet instead of my long-form
interviews which range from one to four
hours that's long if you want those you
can find 300-plus at Tim blog forward
slash podcast but this particular
episode is going to be a short one it
will be roughly 10 minutes in length and
it explains how to 10x your thinking and
your goals or put another way how to
escape incremental thinking and think
truly big that's capital b.i.g and I
love this audio so much that I now
listen to it on a regular basis as a
reminder and even if you only listen
repeatedly to the first minute or so the
exercise that is described it can be
tremendously powerful so perhaps you
will end up doing the same thing and
listening to it every Monday or once
every month or whatever the speaker is
dr. Astro teller at Astro teller on
Twitter Astro is currently captain of
moonshots yes that's his title but you
could think of him as CEO of X formerly
known as Google X but now alphabets
moonshot Factory for building magical
audacious ideas that through science and
technology can be brought to reality
Astro is also a co-founder and current
director of cerebellum Capital a hedge
fund management firm whose investments
are continuously designed executed and
improved by a software system based on
techniques from statistical machine
learning he was also the co-founder and
CEO of BodyMedia Inc a leading wearable
body monitoring company that was sold
the jawbone in 2013 and dr. teller Astro
as I call him holds a Bachelor of
Science in computer science from
Stanford Masters of Science and symbolic
and heuristic computation also from
Stanford University not only would I not
qualify to study such a thing I can
barely pronounce it and a PhD in
artificial intelligence from Carnegie
Mellon University where he was a
recipient of the prestigious Hertz
fellowship the
audio that you're gonna hear was
recorded as part of a 360 that's the
letter a360
a high-end membership group run by past
podcast guests and founder and chairman
of the XPrize Foundation Peter Diamandis
a very impressive guy in his own right
for more on a 360 we want to know how
this group comes together what it
involves and its digital cousin or
version you can think of it abundance
digital since a 360 is in person and
abundance digital is as you would guess
digital please check out Diamandis com
that's D I am a and D is calm and look
under memberships so without further ado
please enjoy Astro teller CEO of X on
how to think 10 times bigger ask for
teller please come on up love this moon
all right you guys having fun awesome so
I run an experiment very frequently I've
done it before in this room and
typically it's with people who are one
or two layers below you in organizations
much like yours I'll leave it as an
exercise to the reader with it they're
just like yours now here's what the
experiment looks like I asked people I'm
going to give you two choices choice a
choice B choice a you can give a million
dollars bottom line to your company
through your efforts this year
guaranteed 100% that's choice a choice B
you can give a billion dollars bottom
line to your company through your
efforts this year with one chance in a
hundred choice a choice B who'll adds to
do choice a who's going to do choice a
for the company absolutely nobody raises
their hand who's gonna do choice B
everybody raises their hand so
congratulations I mean I'm not even
testing you guys I'm sure you can all do
the math in your head the expected
utility is 10 times as high for choice B
as for choice a you
Worsley these people are listening to me
because they think that I'm gonna give
them the special sauce about how to make
innovation and I say you are do you know
the answer now here's the tricky bit
does your boss want you to pick choice a
raise your hand if you think that your
boss would let you pick choice B not a
single hand in the room goes up they
don't need a lecture for me in how to be
innovative they need to change their
context or maybe their boss can become
smart just before they quit on mass and
change the context for them the context
matters so much the expectations matter
so much the people matter the resources
matter but that's not the biggest issue
there have been these times in the world
and sadly they've been mostly military
in nature where you get a huge number of
really smart people together you know
not 5 or 10 but a hundred or more and
you give them the resources but much
more importantly the expectation that
they will produce miracles the founding
of Bletchley Park and the creation of
the modern modern computer science and
cryptography or the harnessing of the
atom at the Manhattan Project these are
examples that we're all sort of well
schooled in and I like the phrase
moonshot thinking because it points us
at one of the few examples
this is JFK's speech at Rice University
and then the Apollo 11 mission after
that that actually puts someone on the
moon to remind us it doesn't have to be
about war that you can create that same
kind of exigency without war why do we
have to wait for a war to say to a group
of people you can do it you can go ten
times bigger you can change the world
that much a huge change not an
incremental change I expect that from
you and I don't want you metaphorically
and literally to choose choice a your
job is choice
be to tell those people and to give them
that freedom so the question is are you
in that context are you creating that
context for your organization because
that's the hard part is you know people
will flock to you once you actually
created the context they're not that
hard to find it's making the context
that's the hard part
so you need to set up part of your
organization I don't think it's
realistic to think all of your
organization can be like this it's very
hard to think and I don't think it's
realistic that everyone's gonna be
choosing choice B you need some people
choosing choice a but they can't all be
choosing choice a so you need to take a
set of people and you put them on the
side this is probably not 50% of your
company's resources but it's not 1%
either it's probably like 5 or 10% you
can afford it
you can't afford not to over some 10
year period actually you will be eaten
alive because other people are getting
better at doing this maybe it's not
worth it who cares why go big like that
you know
Icarus died and Daedalus lived right so
maybe that's maybe incremental
improvement slow and steady wins the
race we have all these phrases for that
let me give you I have all these sort of
perspectives in my mind and why this
doesn't work but here's one of my
favorite ones how many of you know the
mutilated checkerboard problem it's a
famous psychology experiment from almost
40 years ago now so here's how it works
somebody sits down each of the subjects
with a checkerboard and which has 64
squares on it if you haven't looked
recently and gives them 32 dominoes each
Domino can perfectly cover a vertical or
horizontal pair of squares and says to
each of the subjects can you cover this
board perfectly with your dominoes and
every single subject independent of IQ
within 30 seconds says yeah duh and then
they get a little devious the researcher
does and cuts off the upper-left-hand
square from the checkerboard and the
bottom-right-hand square and now says
and takes away one of their dominoes and
says can you still cover you have 30 62
squares and 31 dominoes
can you still cover your board with
these dominoes and now every single
person
independent of IQ stalls in unable to
demonstrate a solution or prove that
there isn't one doesn't swim it could be
that hard turns out it is now if the
researcher writes the word salt just the
word salt on the white squares and
pepper on the black squares everyone
solves it within 30 seconds everybody
and peanut-butter-and-jelly will work as
well maybe better if they're brown and
red and the the insight is that that
you've had to salts or two peppers
depending on the orientation of board
removed and each domino covers one salt
and one pepper whichever way you turn it
so there's now not the same number of
salt and peppers left the perspective
shift is what it's all about that's why
going ten times bigger is more important
and works better than going ten percent
bigger when you shoot for ten percent
better you're in a smartness contest
you're putting all of your people in a
smartness contest with everyone else in
the world they're not going to win it
doesn't matter how much money you give
them but if you push them if you give
them the expectation and the freedom to
be weird
that's moonshot thinking then they can
do the perspective shifts and not only
if you shoot for ten times bigger
instead of ten percent bigger it's
almost never a hundred times harder and
the payoff is a hundred times so you
already know that you've got a better
return on your investment but sometimes
it's literally easier and the reason is
because that perspective shift is
actually cheap relative to being smarter
than everyone around you so one of the
things that I get from so you need to
create this organization that looks more
like Willy Wonka's chocolate factory
than an incubator or an Innovation
Center anyplace that's called an
Innovation Center isn't almost by
definition and you need to fill it with
Peter Pan's with PhDs people who
underwear t-shirts that say safety third
on them right
that's you need these people to
understand and to feel good about the
fact that they're going to fail most of
the time it's not maybe there's no way
that they won't fail most of the time
and you have to impress upon them and it
is possible they love it once you let
them go it's not just a moonshot and
moonshot thinking when you choose to go
big at the high level you impress upon
them that it's moonshots all the way
down that in every subproblem rather
than being clinical and traditional
about how they approach the architecture
for that problem or hiring people for
that problem or how they fail fast and
test things for that problem they can be
weirder they can shoot to be 10 times
better than anyone has ever done before
each of those subproblems and in each of
those ways it will again pay off because
the perspective shifts will unlock more
than smartness well and my at least my
experiences if these people are
surrounded by adora of business speak
you will ruin it all if they believe
that they have to have a business plan
for the weirdness that they are embarked
upon you will kill it absolutely
stillbirth guaranteed but if you tell
them that moonshot thinking is
identifying an enormous problem with the
world picking a science fiction sounding
product or service which if it could be
made would make that problem go away and
that there's some set of technical
plausibly reasons at least a glimmer of
hope that you could actually make that
science fiction sounding product or
service that would make that problem go
away that problem making it go away is
unlocking enormous value in the world
have faith if you solve that problem the
money will come find your organization
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by LegalZoom
which more than 2 million Americans have
used to help start their businesses past
guests even such as while WordPress the
developer CEO of automatic Matt
Mullenweg now valued at more than a
billion dollars have used LegalZoom to
help with their business needs
specifically in his case to form his
company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NBA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour
because Legal Zoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get ala carte style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all of their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is
but it's titillating if you want special
savings enter promo code Tim T I am at
checkout capital T lowercase I am again
take a peek legalzoom.com
and enter promo code Tim
you